did to catch a predator perform a public
service or was it just another ratings
hungry reality series however you feel
about NBC's hit program we've dug up a
collection of behind the scenes details
that might change your opinion
questionable content almost instantly To
Catch a Predator caused the stir amongst
reporters who felt the segment went too
far
not just in content but in execution CBS
News Brian Montopolis accused the series
of being interested in nothing more than
ratings arguing it didn't operate with
enough journalistic integrity
furthermore one totally accused the
segment of taking the law into its own
hands by publicly exposing child
molesters on national television
harsha's his opinion of the show might
be maaan table also made it clear he
feels no sympathy for the men exposed
through its efforts entrapment or
enticement anyone in the business of
rooting out illegal behavior runs the
risk of being accused of entrapment but
according to Dateline correspondent
Stone Phillips there's a fine line
between entrapment and enticement and
it's always clear that the show's
targets and no strangers to predatory
practices online clearly no arms are
twisted to get these men to engage in
sexually explicit online chats and since
the stated intent of the house visit is
to have sex with a minor the ultimate
responsibility lies with the men who
come knocking on the door no matter who
initiates the meeting don't mess with
taxes not all the perps collared by the
show have been given the punishment they
seem to deserve after the segment nabbed
24 men in Murphy Texas the local
district attorney refused to prosecute
the cases claiming the amateur
involvement of perverted justice the
foundation that teamed with NBC to
create to catch a predator tainted them
the DA had backup from Murphy's mayor
who said that even though the men in
question deserved punishment the
involvement of a television show raised
questions local residents were also
furious the
show lured pedophiles to that town and
to a house only two blocks from a school
death of a predator the negative
reaction to the show in Murphy Texas was
largely caused by the suicide of Luis
Conrad he previously been chatting with
perverted justice and had requested
illegal images from someone identifying
as a minor but he didn't actually go to
the predator house instead dateline
waited outside his residence for hours
until the SWAT team arrived as they made
entry they confronted a suspect I
believe is in the hallway and he told
them he wasn't hurt them and then John
coming here state investigators found
child pornography amongst Conrad
possessions as well as evidence of
graphic online chats his sister Patricia
Conrad filed a hundred million dollar
lawsuit against NBC claiming her
brother's exposure caused him to commit
suicide by 2008 the lawsuit was amicably
resolved in a confidential settlement
thrown out of court a 26 year old man
arrested for trying to have relations
with a 13 year old girl would yet
another nail in to catch a predator
scoffing when the case went to trial in
2011 the judge threw it out after only
six days saying that there was no
evidence that the man intended to have
relations with a minor in addition the
judge also accused the segment of
entrapment after the trial the
defendants mother vowed to sue NBC to
reclaim the money spent defending her
son out of cash after NBC stopped airing
segments of To Catch a Predator
perverted justice blew through the 1.2
million they learned and they've since
become strapped for cash though the
group is non profit group founder Xavier
Vaughn Kirk reportedly spent the NBC
money on himself his friends and his
website second thoughts by 2007 to catch
a predator had collected a lot of
negative press including heavily
critical stories in Rolling Stone and
Esquire
some of Dateline's advertisers expressed
misgivings about continuing to support
the segment
as a result NBC started scaling back
production by August of that year only
one segment had been shot compared to
seven the previous year
NBC claimed it wasn't distancing itself
from its controversial hit but the
numbers showed otherwise Chris Hansen
Cheeta Chris Hansen a 20-year veteran at
NBC was ultimately canned after getting
caught red-handed himself he and a
florida affiliate reporter got a little
too close for comfort which wouldn't
normally be a huge problem but Hansen
was married at the time the network
sustained a bit of a black eye during
the scandal and some might say they
dropped the ball by not firing him on a
segment similar to his own so you've got
a big afternoon planned huh predator
reborn there's something you need to
know I'm Chris Hansen and you are going
to help me catch predators again in 2015
Chris Hansen launched a Kickstarter
campaign to fund a web series called
Hansen versus Predator with plans to
bring it to television later he claimed
viewers were hungry for another
investigation and he meant to say that
hunger by May he'd raised almost $90,000
and started production with
investigations already underway
Hansen hired in August 2016
Hansen was hired to host the nationally
syndicated series crime watch daily
which celebrated his arrival by renaming
itself crime watch daily with Chris
Hansen as part of the deal he agreed to
make his Hansen vs. predator web series
part of the program predators around the
world you're on notice with your help
I'll get that next group of predators
very soon thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know what
you think of to catch a predator
[Music]